many people put off routine health exams
during the pandemic
but now that we're fully reopened again
it's time to take care of yourself
in today's buddy check 8 report denise
valdez
brings us the story of a local woman
whose fight against cancer
could have much different results had
she postponed
her routine screening pamela denney
is living proof that early detection
saves lives
aren't you glad that you had your
routine mammogram i mean you walked in
there was like oh this just business as
usual
and it was not business as usual
absolutely and
my surgeon was amazed i'm amazed they
found it so small like one centimeter
size of a
they said like an eraser on the end of a
pencil a routine mammogram
an ultrasound then an mri guided biopsy
led to a dreaded diagnosis she called me
immediately in
early november of 2019 and let me know
that i did have breast cancer it was
called invasive lobular carcinoma denny
credits a
keen-eyed radiologist and committed
doctors for spotting it so quickly
i've been told it's very small and i was
lucky it was stage one
um i thought well why not do the least
invasive thing go with a lumpectomy and
you know and then you do have to have
radiation after that
she started radiation in march of 2020
just as the world was shutting down she
was starting the fight of her life
now more than a year later she reminds
every woman to never take routine care
for granted
i definitely tell everyone that i know
go
get your annual exam you just never know
in denny's case the cancer was caught
very early giving her options and the
time she needed to make the right choice
for her
for buddy check i'm denise faltes back
to you